the rescued boys are given a full
medical evaluation at a local hospital
in Thailand dr. Robert gladder is an
emergency physician at New York's Lenox
Hill Hospital he's trained to conduct
exams in similar circumstances good
morning nice to have you back at the
table again my pleasure let's talk about
let's talk about the lack of sunlight
for over two weeks right what does that
do to you when you haven't seen sunlight
what we're talking about sensory
deprivation yeah that basically makes
your brain act on very unusual in other
words your heart your blood vessels
there are changes that occur but
ultimately without specific areas of the
brain that are perfused with blood you
start to hallucinate you see things you
hear things you can't really have a
sense of who you are but also others
around you there are 11 to 16 years old
the blame the brain is still developing
executive function is up in the air so
explain how this would affect children
of that particular age well I mean kids
of this age are very resilient between
the ages of 11 and 16 so they have a lot
of reserve in their heart their blood
vessels they're able to sustain and with
Stane stress so in other words their
reserve keeps them going through this
and part of this reserve is actually in
their fat stores because what they have
are lots of brown fat and this is
metabolically active that allowing them
to generate heat because this is exactly
what they need to stay alive and so we
should understand that different from
white fat which is not metabolically
active we hear now that as these boys
are at the hospital they're being kept
in some isolation from family because
they're worried about infection what
types of infections well in general the
thing they're mainly concerned of is its
leptospirosis this is the disease found
in caves and ultimately it's it's it's
transmitted through the urine of bats
and the dropping of bats and also
rodents but the problem is that the the
incubation can be up to three weeks so a
one to two day quarantine period really
wouldn't be sufficient so in my mind I
think really the the psychological
effects are really more severe at this
point so with infection would be less
wouldn't you want to be with your
parents yes idiot Lee and getting Meno
to hug you yes right and this is so
critical I think that children need to
be hugged love is so important support
they have to understand that their pain
are here for them certainly the divers
are there and they've been an incredible
an immense support of love and comfort
as well but it's that unit of parents
and family they're so cute well the
parents have been sending notes to them
to say mommy's here we're waiting for
you
and the kids on the other hand are
sending notes back to their parents to
say don't worry about me I'm fine all is
okay and you see their little smiling
faces but I can't help think how
terrified they must be in the
psychological effects that this could
have on them like what absolutely fear
of the unknown it's dark you know your
your brain does funny things we talked
about sensory deprivation hallucinating
your brain is trying to remain active
keeping itself alert because without
that without that input your brain
really suffers and so while you know
some kids can get better through than
some others you know it's it's really
collectively they have to bond together
and so stimulating themselves talking
know meditating telling stories you know
this is so key and getting through any
kind of very severe and prolonged
situations you must be very encouraged
that was a doctor buy what you're seeing
so far absolutely very encouraged and
you know it's a credit to their strength
their conditioning these kids are an
incredible physical condition but also
mental condition yeah we can see that
from their outcomes
well dr. gladder we've been following
every detail you just saw there's so
much new information that was really
helpful thank you so much appreciate it